I encountered Jim Carter about 18 years
ago through a really bizarre set of
circumstances I was writing a book at
the time about the history of physics
and religion and I used to buy a lot of
second-hand academic books from this
book dealer in LA and one day I was in
there picking up some stuff and she said
Oh Margaret this package arrived in the
mail the other day i was about to chuck
it into the bin when I thought of you
and she handed me this package and in it
was this amazingly sort of fluorescent
colored wall chart which sort of
presented this alternative explanation
of the periodic table on the back side
of the chart it had this guy's
alternative theory of the creation of
the universe and I thought my gosh it's
pretty amazing I've never seen anything
like that this guy was announcing the
self publication of his own book called
the other theory of physics in which he
was purporting to present to us a
complete alternative theory of the
universe he was completely throwing out
relativity and quantum theory and he was
presenting his own physics really that
he built from the ground up and Jim
isn't alone because actually I now have
a collection of these people Jim my guy
Jim Carter has very unusual case because
he has so much physics in he does his
incredible diagrams and animations of
his theories but I too have been
collecting this stuff for about 15 years
and I've got you know two large shelves
on my bookcase full of alternative
theories of the universe and it turns
out these guys have their own
Association it's called the natural
philosophy Alliance and they have annual
meetings and people come from all over
the world and they publish this
proceedings which has about you know 700
pages thick of alternative theories of
the universe and I became intrigued what
does this outpouring of what I've come
to court outsider science say about our
society's relationship to science in
general I don't actually think that any
of the people that I've met have
actually got theories that are ever
going to be taught at Harvard or
Princeton I don't think they're ever
going to win the Nobel Prize and nor do
I think they should what they are doing
is as it were they are a reaction to the
fact that the mainstream physics
theories have got so
difficult to understand things like
general relativity and string theory and
hyperspace theory there's incredibly
beautiful elaborate but highly
mathematical highly technical theories
that physicists are now saying this is
how we describe the ultimate nature of
reality these theories have become
inaccessible to almost everybody in even
most trained physicists have a pretty
hard time understanding string theory in
fact most traders will tell you that
they really don't understand it so where
does that leave the ordinary person one
of the big issues that's confronting our
society now with theoretical physics is
that there are so many competing
theories of physics both in mainstream
physicists and in and from outside the
mainstream part of the issue is going to
be how we as a society going to work out
which theories will pay attention to and
indeed which theories we're going to
spend lots of money testing and one says
this playing out now vis v string theory
it becomes a practical economic question
how much is our society going to spend
on searching for truth Ares of reality
and how are we going to decide among all
the competing theories which ones we are
going to put our vast instruments to
work searching for our society spends
hundreds of millions if not billions of
dollars on these there should be some
gatekeeping going on here but when
anyone can post their theories online as
these guys can do now and the Internet
has been the biggest boom in the world
to outside a theorist you know you can
go on-line and find thousands of
alternative theories of the universe how
are we going to judge one of the
hallmarks of the Enlightenment is that
you know in the last two or three
hundred years we've as it were given
people the means of production in all
sorts of ways that were unthinkable in
the past so for instance in the 18th
century almost nobody would ever hear an
orchestra play almost or would even hear
a violin play but now anyone can
download samples of the London
Philharmonic and create a symphony in
there
I'm bedroom in the 16th century almost
nobody could read let alone right and
now anyone with a laptop can write their
own book and actually publish it online
we applaud this as it were expansion of
the means of production in the DIY
culture like here we are the big thing
making our own fantastic television
program and we we all think this is a
good thing so part of what I'm asking in
this book is where do we draw the line
with the DIY ethos is it unacceptable to
have a DIY theory of physics